Julien bonjour À LA UNE donc de la
presse ce matin notamment cette tempête
au sein du couple mythique européen
effectivement Damien parle bien du
couple franco-allemand moteur de l'Union
européenne un duo qui a pris du plan
dans l'aile depuis plusieurs mois
regardez cette une extrêmement utile
équivoque c'était une de libération et
cette photo montage des deux dirigeants
sur ton dans le dos n'en ai pas encore
au stade du divorce puisque les deux
hommes des jeunes à Paris aujourd'hui
mais ce qui est intéressant quand on
ouvre les pages du quotidien et bien
c'est de voir un peu qui est responsable
selon le journal et bien pour Libération
c'est clair le responsable c'est Olaf
Souls ola soul je cite le perché
allemand le chancelier allemand qui est
dans une tour d'ivoire et qui est le
quotidien s'il a encore des conseils
est-ce qu'il a encore des conseillers
s'il en a est-ce qu'il les écoute se
demande le journal on en prend aussi que
le dirigeant allemand essuie de vie
critique sur le plan intérieur à cause
de l'énergie et que la France passe au
second plan justement la France dans
tout ça que devient-elle et bien la
France elle est un peu comme un avant un
amant pardon qu'on délaisse sans préavis
la France dit ne pas de comprendre ce
virement se revirement allemand nous dit
la croix on va essayer l'éditorial avec
le titre un couple à la peine en
quelques jours Berlin a suscité la
surprise et puis ensuite la colère de
Paris avec notamment vous le disiez à
l'instant des achats d'avions de chasse
américain au détriment des Européens le
plan aussi d'installer un bouclier
anti-missiles américains et une nouvelle
fois non européen mais vous savez Damien
parfois en amour il vaut mieux pour
régler un différent il vaut mieux se
parler autour d'une table c'est toujours
mieux alors on a vu d'idées on a vu la
croix quick de la presse allemande que
disent les journaux c'est dissension
politique et bien là Damien les avis
divergent complètement par exemple pour
le Frankfurter algue minuscitung Paris
je cite ne peut pas comprendre
l'Allemagne qui par ces temps de guerre
l'Allemagne qui veut à tout prix
préserver ses intérêts notamment sur les
plans économiques et militaires on peut
le comprendre d'un certain côté mais
pour le tagueuse Pigal en revanche on
s'inquiète qu'il y ait de l'eau dans le
gaz entre les Français et les Allemands
pourquoi et bien parce que la
coopération franco-allemande est un gage
une garantie je cite liberté et de paix
plus que jamais en ces temps retrouvé
voilà pour ce dossier franco-allemand et
cette rencontre Emmanuel Macron et voilà
ce que l'on va suivre évidemment
aujourd'hui sur France 24 toute cette
journée on parle de l'Italie maintenant
ou de Georgia Meloni donc présenté son
premier discours comme président du
Conseil discours très policé qui visait
d'abord à rassurer les partenaires
européens justement oui avec la hutte de
la République quotidien centriste
mélonie l'équilibriste la dirigeon de
l'extrême droite a rappelé hier dans son
premier discours devant la Chambre des
députés qu'elle respecterait les règles
de l'Union européenne histoire de ne pas
froisser Bruxelles mais dans le même
temps la soutenu ces tests de campagne
notamment en matière de souverainisme et
de défense des intérêts italiens pour il
libéraux quotidien très classé très à
droite c'est en avant toute à droite
réformes fiscale valeur sur les le
travail va leur familiale tout y est
pour plaire à la coalition
gouvernementale c'est un discours je
cite ici et digne d'un chef d'État écrit
le journal en revanche pour il fato
quotidiano qui est plutôt classe à
gauche le discours au lycée ne cache pas
la radicalité des positions avec
notamment je cite un discours
identitaire visant les plus fragiles
avec ce titre ABA les pauvres le journal
qui s'inquiète aussi des nouveaux noms
donné à certains ministères italiens
nous n'as notamment le ministère de la
Famille qui devient aussi celui de la
natalité pardon ou alors encore celui de
l'agriculture qui devient celui de la
souveraineté alimentaire alors ça c'est
donc pour la presse sur place comment
est-ce qu'on voit tout ça depuis
l'étranger cette fois alors le temps du
journal suisse qualifie de ce discours
de politiquement correct mais en même
temps flou puisqu'on a parlé hier de
coopération avec l'Europe de soutien
continu avec l'Ukraine du développement
d'aide aux familles pour pallier la
crise énergétique et aussi du rejet
catégorique du fascisme c'est à demander
si ce n'est pas Mario Draghi
prédécesseur de Georgia Meloni qui a
écrit le discours ironise un politologue
loin de l'image de la candidate radicale
qui faisait peur à une partie de
l'Europe voilà qui nous mène peut-être
en bateau transition toute facile pour
prendre la direction du port
Saint-Nazaire ou vient d'être livré un
bateau de croisière pas n'importe lequel
le dernier cri censé être moins polluant
et plus vert est-ce possible sur le
papier Damien tout est possible dans les
faits cela reste encore à confirmer nous
dit la croix les navires de croisière
sont aussi confirmés par le concerné
pardon par le défi climatique regardez
ici dans le journal La Croix avec cette
photo du MSC World Europa livré à
Saint-Nazaire il y a deux jours c'est le
sixième plus gros paquebot du monde
c'est une sorte d'hôtel ou de
pala-sur-mer il pourrait émettre jusqu'à
25% d'émissions de CO2 en moins pourquoi
et bien parce que nous dit le journal il
est équipé il fonctionnera
essentiellement avec du GNL du gaz
naturel liquéfier alors tout ça Damien
c'est très bien nous répond les ONG
environnementales sauf que si tous les
futurs navires de croisière de cette
taille-là de verroule devait carburer
pardon avec du GNL et bien cela devrait
concerner des quantités astronomiques de
gaz or par les temps qui courent à cause
du conflit avec la Russie ça ne peut pas
être une solution quand on parle de
pollution on parle pas que de CO2 non
nous dit Le Figaro on nous parle aussi
de position sonore on parle beaucoup de
pollution sonore dans les villes avec
les voitures les bateaux les voitures
les avions encore les scooters mais cela
aussi concernent les bateaux nous dit
Figaro cela perturbe la faune exemple
ici juste là avec la question des
baleines dont Louis quand elles sont à
plusieurs centaines de mètres de
profondeur sous l'océan donc quand il
n'y a plus de lumière louez bien et leur
seul moyen pour se repérer et
pourchasser leur proie un rapport du
Parlement européen suggère donc de
limiter la vitesse de ces bateaux pour
faire moins de bruit et pour que l'océan
redevienne en quelque sorte le monde du
silence qu'il était autrefois